how's it going everybody it's Warren and
there is a huge Avengers in game leaked
that came out a couple of days ago it's
really nice to get some leaks for
Avengers in game because although we got
the trailer it didn't really tell us
much it's a teaser trailer it did its
job with this new leak comes some new
information about Avengers endgame so
spoiler alert there are some spoilers
coming in this video also the Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway winner will be chosen
on January 1st so if you would like to
enter the giveaway for your chance to
win all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel with the notifications turned
on like the video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so this leak actually gives us
quite a bit of information what this
leak entails is descriptions for five
different Avengers in game Lego set
pieces so as you can imagine there is
quite a bit of information from these
leaks so I'll just go ahead and break it
down for you so the first one is titled
Captain America attack of the outriders
it is $20 and it's a hundred and
sixty-seven pieces apparently Captain
America did not fight the outriders for
the last time in Avengers infinity war
and we'll be fighting them again in
Avengers endgame there has been talk of
a very huge battle at the end of
Avengers in game between the Avengers
and Thanos obviously as expected it will
most likely be a scene like the Battle
of Wakanda except Thanos will actually
be there so in this huge battle at the
end of Avengers in game where the
Avengers are fighting Thanos the
outriders will most likely be there
fighting with Thanos so this Lego set is
most likely from Captain America in the
in battle fighting some of the outriders
and more on this at the end of this
video the next Lego set is titled war
machine crusher it's $35 and 362 pieces
so we have leaked photos of war machine
and he does look pretty beefy in these
photos so it's clear that war machine is
getting some sort of an upgrade and when
I hear war machine crusher I think
proton cannon a lot of people think that
the cryptic photo that the Russo
brothers put on social media actually
shows war machines proton cannon in it
we know that he's going to get a beefy
suit upgrade so maybe with that suit
upgrade comes a mass
weapon upgrade the proton cannon the
suit upgrade along with the proton
cannon upgrade would definitely qualify
rody as war machine crusher the next
description is really awesome it's
called Iron Man armor room it's $60 and
has 524 pieces so we're starting to get
up there in pieces a five hundred and
twenty four piece set is a huge set but
really what's exciting is the
description Iron Man armor room so back
when infinity war was announced there
was a concept art photo that came out
and it showed Iron Man in front of a
bunch of Iron Man suits so keep in mind
that they shot Avengers infinity war and
Avengers in game back to back and some
scenes even at the same time so it seems
like we might see this scene from what
we thought was unused concept art in
Avengers end game also note that we
could see the iron Legion and Avengers
in game as well recently there has been
a leak that said the iron Legion is
going to be in spider-man far from home
and even though Tony technically
destroyed the iron Legion it does seem
like there's going to be some form of it
in avengers endgame based off this
concept art photo and the leak that
we've heard about spider-man far from
home this could also be where Tony
develops the mark 85 armor that is also
said to be an Avengers in game as well
and again armor room proton cannon could
be in there just saying so the next set
that we have is titled Avengers super
Quinn jet it's $80 and 832 pieces so a
super Quinn jet that doesn't really give
us too much information however there is
said to be a ton of heroes in this movie
and it's said that they're all going to
be on screen at the same time so this
simply could be just exactly what it
says it is a super Quinn jet that is
massive in size that is used to carry
all of the heroes or it could be a Quinn
jet that they modify and enhance to take
inside of the quantum realm we've
already seen leaked photos of what
appears to be quantum realm suits that
the Avengers wear so we know they go
inside of the quantum realm and an
ant-man and the wasp we see dr. Hank Pym
go inside of the quantum realm in a
vessel as well so it's not really much
of a stretch to think that the Avengers
would design some sort of ship to go
inside of the quantum realm that takes
them all in together this is just
speculation but we do know from this
leak that we are going
get some sort of super Quinn jet in
avengers endgame okay so this next and
final set piece is the big one it's
called battle of the assembled Avengers
it's $100 and 699 pieces I don't know
about you but the first thing that I
thought of when I heard this was Captain
America finally saying Avengers Assemble
which I really hope we get because we
already know that there's going to be a
massive fight scene in Avengers endgame
it was leaked when some of the actors
were doing interviews they said that
there's going to be over 40 different
characters in one scene so the Avengers
are technically assembled so I really
hope it's Captain America yelling
Avengers Assemble to get them all
together but what this leak does tell us
is that there's going to be a huge scene
where all of the Avengers and the heroes
are together this is of course most
likely the final fight scene right now
some of the Avengers are together on
earth such as Thor Black Widow Captain
America the Hulk but then you're missing
Tony and nebula and not to mention the
ones that are dead so the fact that we
know that there's a scene out there that
has 40 different heroes means that we
know that they're going to come back
somehow because right now all we really
have is the original Avengers and a
couple of guardians so the only way to
have a huge scene with all of these
characters in it is if the ones that are
dead come back and this is a really big
set at six hundred and ninety-nine
pieces so what this most likely is is
that rumored seem to be happening where
over forty different heroes come
together and fight Thanos all at once
and this is just more evidence that we
are going to get that final battle and
we know that the heroes that died due to
the snap are going to come back somehow
we have spider-man far from homecoming
out so we know that spider-man's going
to come back and even dave bautista
straight-up said in an interview that
he's coming back so we know that all of
the Fallen Heroes are going to be coming
back there is rumors of a scene where
all of the heroes go against Thanos in
one fight scene and now we have a leaked
Lego set titled battle of the assembled
Avengers so it does look very likely
that we're going to get this huge battle
at the end of Avengers endgame so there
you have it there are all of the recent
leaks and what they could potentially
reveal about Avengers endgame what do
you all think about these linked
descriptions
do you think we're going to get this
huge final fight scene where all of the
Avengers go against Thanos all at once
let me know what you think in the
comments down below and again only a
couple of days left in the giveaway if
you would like to enter for your chance
to win a life-sized Infinity Gauntlet
all you have to do is subscribe to my
channel but the notifications turned on
like the video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero as always thank you all so
much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]